uh we do have Hikaru Nakamura who is
making his uh debut here at the American
Cup Hikaru welcome to the studio first
round first win how do you feel right
now yeah it's pretty good I mean I I I'm
on I was on a one game losing streak
having not played classical chess in
something like nine months
um so it was quite nice to get a win I
mean I think the game is very
interesting uh I noticed it was kind of
similar to lavon's game that they're
double triple pawns everywhere on the
board
um which was you know kind of
interesting but I I don't think it was
ever really
um tricky per se for me a lot of my
decisions were pretty straightforward
unfortunately for Sam without a second
time control in particular it was very
very difficult and he just didn't find
the right continuations I mean I think
um probably he started going wrong
pretty early on I mean I think I think
okay this is all completely fine of
course uh and yeah I mean takes takes
how did you assess this position yeah I
mean I thought I was better actually
okay castles is all right I didn't play
castles because I was worried about uh
like I thought he could go like Queen E8
and then some F6 and C5 and queen F7 and
I mean I guess wow it's not that much
better for white that's surprising I
thought it was better I just didn't know
how much better
yeah well I mean if I was 3500 I could
play I could Castle I mean I considered
it but I just didn't really see and I
thought rookdale was the other thematic
move because black can't go C5
um that being said I thought that after
Queen E8 for example castles
C5 Bishop C3 F6 I know it looks very
ugly for black but white doesn't really
have a whole lot going on
um I mean okay it wants to go B3 and
claim some big advantage in the long
term but at least for me looking at this
while it looks ugly for black I didn't
see a clear way to progress here at some
point I can try F4 and E5 to break in
the center but I I don't really think
it's that easy to do and I thought it
was better I didn't think it was a whole
lot
um I thought what Sam did also should
have been okay but yeah already here it
gets it's kind of tricky because you
feel like you're very close to a draw
but you can also be very far from a
drawn I think one he played um G takes
F6 this was really the start of his big
problems here takes takes and not taking
with the Rook basically what I concluded
is that here after Rook takes let's just
say I go Rook D3 for example king f8
um Rook C1 King E7 I don't know takes
takes Rook C3 King D7 here I mean white
is better of course but if black and
Goldberg B and like just as just say
white plays like G3 here just Rook B8 B3
and then Rook b60 even I think black
should be okay here because you have the
active rook and The Rook on B6 is
passive temporarily but you can always
go Rook before later on so I thought
this was the best setup
um whereas in the game once you got once
you get these double pawns on F6 I mean
I think uh it's really really hard to
play because I never have to trade off
the pawn on C5 or D6 and then he has to
take the triple pawns on the C file and
from there I mean I suspect a computer
still will find some way to hold it but
it didn't seem practical in the game you
mentioned uh the absence of the second
time controller uh did that play into
your decision to enter these two result
end game no I mean I I haven't played
classical chess in a very long time so I
just want to do something simple
um and really I think that's the main
thing is you never really you never know
how you're going to react when you
haven't played for so long I mean
obviously when I played in Berlin after
after an even longer break I did quite
well but nonetheless I wasn't really
sure and I also felt that Sam he's a
much more tactical aggressive player
that's not to say that he can't play
positional shots but I feel like that's
his strength and so of getting him out
of that I thought gave me better chances
absolutely and when did you feel like
you're closing the show
um I felt around the time that he he got
stuck when he didn't play C5 so when he
played Rook B6 yeah right around here we
were discussing C5 here we felt that C5
was was the better move okay interesting
computer still thinks it's really bad
wow but you know it's also always hard
to judge because basically just as an
example say go King G3 Rook B6 say Rook
takes C4 Rook B2 Rook C5 it doesn't
matter Rook A2 and just like I don't
know Rook A7 A5 like it you never really
know because this end game if Rook takes
A5 if basically Rook takes A5 is later
yeah I just mean if we get this end game
where I have
have an extra Pawn
um this is this is a draw so you're
never really sure whether it's
completely winning or not
um but somewhere around here when he got
stuck with this Rook on B6 I eventually
was able to play A4 A5 it felt like it
had to be winning and Sam was getting
low on the clock as well and yeah I I
don't think I was really ever thinking
about like when it was winning or not
winning but I just kept trying to play
the best moves and it seemed to work out
talk to us about the format of this
tournament how do you feel that impacts
your decision-making process
um well you mean having a loser bracket
or yes loser bracket as well as all the
time controls available yeah I don't
think it really changes much uh I mean
really the only thing I'm trying to do
is not lose games in classical chats so
I can keep my rating otherwise that's
all that I'm doing so I I'm not really
thinking that much about the format um
but of course I think it's great that
for example if you have one really bad
day and you lose a match uh you have a
chance to come back and redeem yourself
so I think from that standpoint it's
quite good guys any questions
wonderfully uh done I thought it was a
very instructive uh game Hikaru and good
luck tomorrow
thank you absolutely as we have